cuál es el costo de 14.6 litros de
gasolina si cada litro cuesta 270 y lo
que haremos es lo siguiente vamos a
multiplicar 14.6
de los litros por 2 puntos 70 que lo
pondré cómo 2.7
para que nosotros podamos hacer esta
multiplicación realmente lo que
ocuparemos es
utilizar estos números como si fueran
enteros y ya más tarde nos haremos cargo
de los decimales así es que
multiplicaremos como si esto fuera 146
por 27 empecemos nuestra multiplicación
haremos 7 por 6 42 y reagrupó 4
7 por 4 28 4 32 al grupo 3
7 por 173
ahora vamos con el siguiente con el 2
este 374 por el momento no les haré caso
este no realmente lo tomaremos como si
fuera 20
así es que así que aquí colocaremos un 0
2 por 6
re grupo 1 2 x 4 819 y 2 x 1 2
entonces puedo hacer ya mis sumas 20 22
09 9 12
así es que si multiplicamos 146 por 27
nuestra respuesta sería 3 1942 pero
vamos a hacernos cargo ahora de los
puntos decimales que tenemos aquí los
estoy marcando muy grandes y aquí como
contaremos donde colocar nuestro punto
decimal en la respuesta en el producto
que tenemos aquí contaremos en los
números originales cuántos números están
hacia la derecha del decimal en nuestro
primer número tenemos 1
y en el segundo número tenemos 1 así es
que tenemos 2 en total nuestro producto
tendrá 2 números a la derecha del punto
decimal así es que será 1 2
y esta será nuestra respuesta cuál es el
costo de 14.6 litros de gasolina si cada
litro cuesta 270 pues sera
39 punto 42 por el total de los 14
puntos 6 litros de gasolina